chiodi succhiato [ __ ] tua madre l
tutti ragazze venute questo video sono
un panda a figo e oggi siamo sull'under
island specie o poi è stato un i
primissimi giochi che ho fatto sul
canale proprio tipo tre anni fa adesso è
uscita la versione completa adesso
distante ci ha messo giusto cinque
minuti giorno tanto si capisce mai una
mazza di come si parte negli horror
quindi va bene così anche se ti stai
alzando da zero ma certo è ovvio ma
guarda stavi pescando con la zia pina
quindi l'obiettivo è salvarsi le chiappe
o trovare la zia ha proprio il fatto che
non mi ricordo manco la demo click to
use c'è un pupazzo a come lo sto tenendo
questo accendino col pensiero perché
dovrebbe essere andata lì credo perché
ci ha scritto the mill scusi lei lo sa
che c'è mia zia dentro quel mulino nel
mulino che vorrei c'è soltanto farisei
che cazzo va anche lei devo andare
proprio dove ti stai dove sta i
camminanti puoi levare dar cazzo per
cortesia torna in ghiacciaia cazzo
questo qua le idee ben chiare su cosa
fare bravo di mao ragazzi c'è hagrid con
l'ascia non ho capito il senso di sta
cosa però è questo devo fare la maniglia
della porta
ok man show questa è la casa di hagrid
c'è un lucchetto
mi manca ovviamente la chiave quindi non
posso aprire posso uscire senza che
qualcuno mi stupri l'anno grazie da gol
ragazzi proprio vedere un po in giro
perché non ho capito qual è l'obiettivo
del gioco però moore ha quindi posso
usare questo come arma per difendere il
posso suonare
ah sì così è questo l anno cazzo sei
incazzato via veloce la cena ce lo score
di garri no no no no no no no cazzo
bye bye bye bye bye che non doveva
suonare la campana perché la campana fa
incazzare hagrid dove cazzo merda gode
succhia
ma [ __ ] tua madre su gesù non uno
che non ti prendo schiaffi perché la
merda schizza un po trovato una [ __ ]
chiave visto cuscino del cazzo che è
colpa tua a qualcosa sta chiave deve non
ho tra cui continua a guardarti uomini e
donne come se non ci fosse un domani non
ti preoccupare antica col cazzo non si
scontra voi che era questa la chiave è
fantastico io ho trovato ancora ancorato
sta minchia di pupazzo della minkia c'è
uno stivale mio questo posso uno stivale
grazie posso prendere a calci in culo
colpirla quando trova la chiave sono il
bambino più contento del mondo che ha
aperto questo io so cosa parole chiave
hai rotto il cazzo si è passati agli
stivali dal dottor martens alle ciabatte
della de fonseca non pensavo che volesse
aprire un footlocker no di melo che lo
facciamo download jackets
ovviamente c'è scritto che il bagno il
figo di prima tornerà nella foresta se
riceve i suoi stivali mancanti ai delle
ciabatte che ti invidia anche capitan
sparrow che cosa minchia vuoi di più
c'è un altro ma cazzo ma di chi lo paga
cioè io entrambi gli stivali possiamo
aprire negozio frotte sega eccolo aprire
mi sono nascosto sotto le giustamente
facce gli anelli gli stivali cazzo
riguarda che non si fanno sconti qui è
per amici fan culo e ci paghi il prezzo
pieno
stronzo pure cosa fatta entrare che più
alto di gesù che sarà l'anti sia aperto
grazie dell'ospitalità buono c'era uno
che parlava prima
che bello che non riesco ma allora se il
personaggio lo fai alto due metri
cazzo ma almeno altre due metri le porte
che non se no sembra che entri nel muro
ma casey ma ci vuole tanto e ignorants
proprio permesso
ho capito che la casetta dei sette nani
questa però
no
ma è giusto o è uscita alzate era ancora
tu mica che caricherà che picchia fai
pure subacquee grande possiamo andar via
gola zattera piede di porco grazie
questo mi serve non si sa mai caduta in
testa a qualcuno perché non debbo a
forzare proprio la porta del mulino nel
mulino che vorrei
sforza solo i fatti miei se ci mando fa
vj siamo tutti tranne i gay ha
funzionato l'abbia fatta ok forse c'era
un look che cazzo mette il lucchetto se
poi devi aprirla cos'è mi chiamava
sempre ragazzi siamo passati dall isola
che non c'è ci sia proprio i beats 6 e
sboccato e nel mare proprio ibiza c'è
dubbio ma no mi fai vedere il paradiso
per cinque secondi e poi ma [ __ ]
andare ancora il mulino tra l'altro come
se non bastasse permesso allora c'era
ancora un'altra via fantastico c'è già
non capisco dove sto andando di mio
figlio mettiti pure mettimi pure altre
vie si vabbè ragazzi per cortesia vabbè
dai ormai capito io seguo segua la
strada per il mulino bene e rossi i casi
che rossi tacche file e uova di pasqua
ma zio è una scala di 13 metri dove
minchiate la si è infilata permesso
posso entrare ciechi hegel mora che fa
sto rumore liano era il mulino qual era
il senso ho trovato la pistola sulla
pistola
ma chi è o trovato la pistola spara
dardi e ora per l'emozione cielo
ciao frate è no io ho una pistola
cioè non ti conviene perché poi ti
picchio la mamma divisa sono tratte
pizza e pisa sono dove cazzo ecco
infatti sono cioè questa edizione non sa
cosa fai conclamazione cosa fai perché
dovunque vado mi piano ammazzate quel
problema di sta gente che cazzo vuole
mai quantifica una palata in faccia che
poi io la pistola tra l'altro non vorrei
dire dove cazzo siamo così a caso
abbiamo cambiato location va bene
comunque ho una pistola posso usarla
spero mayo rose mansion ha quindi è la
casa del sindaco il sindaco fatto dire
da poco una città de mer da quanto ho
capito una volta era una bella isola
solo che poi è diventata le apro la
porta a messi e non si apre in cassa il
te pareva avanti il vetro era eccitato
nel vedermi se mi fate cagare in mano vi
ammazzo la famiglia in tre pezzi
illuminati nominati illuminati questo e
questo ci sta la conferma perfetto
adesso possa andare avanti
un filo nel muro
[Musica]
c'è gran figata big murray
[ __ ] chi cazzo sei che versa in
sempre più bello del ragno mi mi piace
ti giuro preferisco questo all'anno
preferisco questo raggiro facciamo un
patto spunta mi sempre tu ti prego iddio
ma non il ragno che cazzo devo fare io
una volta che quel tizio mi entra in
campo ti apri per cortesia ma non mi
toccare mirate attuale allora sentite
devo affrontare il ragno per favore che
cazzo saresti tutti noi al fratello
nuova oh oh oh mamma vi dovete crepare
tutti i libri morite to bastardi
anche tu sei proprio stronzo dentro ma
di melo è la madonna e poi scopro che
che era un'altra la strage della giusta
grazie gioco sempre di aiuto complimenti
mi devo aspettare che mi spunti obama
oppure posso andare avanti tranquillo
permesso
lo chiede per me è [ __ ] ancora tu
c'è palle la faccia di che cosa aprendo
a sedia e corri corri veloce
deciditi da dove mica vuoi arrivarmi da
una porta o dall'alto di una delle due
decide e tieni quella potermi spunta
davanti faccio affrontare ti correnti a
destra
adesso però c'è veloce oddio chi cazzo
viola serie a2 cazzolato cos'è non ho
neanche visto cosa è successo a bene
bravo la soluzione migliore non avrei
saputo far di meglio bravissimo frane
che visto da un certo punto dato una
testata una porta che sia aperta da sola
va bene così mi sono pagato il pene
visti posti che vi prego iddio e dai sei
sulla strada avevamo passano agip se
solo su un'isola deserta manco fossi
lost come ma se siamo solo a cazzo di
isola come è possibile dove l'autostrada
spiegami che passi sotto l'oceano e
questo ovviamente ibiza poi tra 5 minuti
ci troviamo di nuovo a prenderla nel ca
pranzi da degli agri che camminano però
come quanto sono note
e invece no mi scusi lei che sta in
doccia non voglio disturbare per carità
qui capisco di essere una persona che
nella vita ha avuto un gran bel culo
possa appoggiarti il malleolo sul
coccige però ragazzi bisogna riconoscere
che è una donna quindi bisogna farle
fare cose da me ne frega un cazzo se sei
in doccia va in cucina posso entrare
segno da non segno da però delle
mutandine potresti anche metterti ciao
zia affiorano ragazzi che con quello che
l'episodio di lamber island che è stato
il primo ma è una figata pazzesca anche
il continuo questo lo posso assicurarti
il primo era un po più isis vero che
video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi come sento
seguito è piaciuto lasciato quanto è un
mi piace anche a pagina di facebook che
come livido sulla transizione servizi di
skype ci vediamo nel prossimo libro del
ragazzo